I became a piece of crap in the eyes of
the active duty seal Community for the
stuff I was putting online when I
started getting messages from people
that I served with like literally was
taking incoming fire with this person
and they're sending me messages that are
not Anonymous they're like you
don't ever say that online again you're
disowned from the community no yeah and
so it was like heartbreaking and so I
ended up deleting everything but Tik Tok
was becoming a thing right around the
time that I was like okay I'm done
posting about seal stuff I'm giving it
up and I was like well there's probably
not any seals on there you know it's
probably just like kids doing dances so
I post this Tik Tok and I leave my phone
in my room and then I go with my kids my
wife down to the water park like having
fun and I come back and my phone is like
practically broken it's got so many
notifications popping up on it the video
that I posted had like 5 million views
in like literally a couple of hours I
posted three stories like that one a day
for 30 days I grew my Tik Tok account to
like a million followers in 30 days